[Music]
I'm the one
yeah oh my gosh we had to start it at
this time because if we would have
started at 10 seconds ago 20 seconds ago
you would have had a heard a dirty joke
by Tom yes or no yes a bad joke it was
amazing from Tom having to do with
something that vibrates a lot but we're
not going to talk about that we're not
going to talk about that
yeah in epileptic stock analysts anyways
we got Jed in the house Jedediah Bila in
the house just crossed 200 000 Subs put
a link below if you haven't yet
subscribed go find her so we got Vinnie
or Shana come here about the rest of the
house we did a special clip recently me
and you Gemma cast it we were in Ukraine
or Russia where was it at we're in yeah
Vinny's in the house we got Tom
Ellsworth bizdoc Monday morning in the
house he got a lot of stuff to do
business obviously uh uh we got a lot of
stories to go through ton to discuss Jed
is here to give us her point of view on
what's going on with Tucker obviously
there's a lot to talk about who's going
to replace him you've been at Fox before
you worked there you work with pretty
much everybody and so we want to see
what you have to say about Dan Tom's got
some opinions about the market I thought
it was going to be Vinnie but today is
going to be Tom you're welcome about
what happened with First Republic Bank
and FDIC
uh uh what happened there why is Jamie
Diamond all excited about First Republic
and partially getting the government to
get involved to buy the dirty paper
anyways we'll talk about that big Tech
earnings spark hope that the worse is
over yet at the same time home prices in
March posted biggest annual decline in
11 years there's a building a 300
million dollar building in San Francisco
that's fully empty pretty much and
they're saying it'll trade possibly for
60 200 million dollars today if you want
to make an offer no one's in that
building and it's at the cream of the
crop area in San Fran Charlie Munger
issues warning for commercial property
Market which is not looking good for
that a story here I almost didn't
believe it until then he had to show to
me over and over and over again from
transgender to trans abled now people
are choosing to identify as handicapped
I explained this to Jen last and she's
like babe what are you talking about I
said I'm telling you this is a real
story any the average person you explain
this to makes no sense I know you have
some thoughts on that God RFK Jr poses a
biological males com competing in
women's sports Jets you got thoughts on
that we have a surprising search of
Faith among young people Furious
religious groups combat Satan Khan with
intense prayer
Vinnie you got some thoughts on that so
does JED Vice is headed to uh bankruptcy
pretty well just a few years ago was a
5.7 billion dollar company now it's
headed into bankruptcy Tom's got updates
on that bunch of things with Ron
DeSantis how bad is it for Ron DeSantis
he's pulling at rfk's level uh Ron
DeSantis could unlock an 86 million
dollar presidential run Bernie Sanders
recently calls for confiscation of
wealth for people above
999 million dollars and Trump imitates
Biden which we should play that clip
here in a minute when we get into it and
last but not least Sanders said Biden
could win in a landslide but before we
do that let's talk about something
important here such as parking
violations in New York city so New York
City Council introduces Bill requiring
richer people to pay more for violations
like parking tickets double parking than
the average person meaning if you make
more money you pay more and California
is doing a similar thing as well there
let me read this story so this this kind
of this to me is strange you just think
about it say hey how much money you make
last year well listen your ticket is
going to be 600 instead of 300 what a
wild situation in New York so here we go
a new bill proposed by New York City
Council would introduce a pilot program
to scale civil fines such as parking
tickets based on a person's income
making richer people pay more for these
fines proponents of the bill argue that
scaling the fees uh would encourage more
people to pay and ensure that the
penalties are fair and proportionate to
person's ability to pay the independent
budget office found that New York City
is owed more than two billion dollars in
unpaid fines from just the last five
years the bill has to survive a hearing
in the council to be reviewed by mayor
Eric Adams once it's introduced similar
programs exist in a handful of cities
around the country and in Europe where
Technologies used to look up taxpayers
income to calculate fines and by the way
California is doing a similar thing
proposed proposed proposing charging
customers based on how much money they
make when it comes down to their
electrical bill so if you make 180 or
more you could pay 85 or more for your
electricity Tom what are your thoughts
on the story uh folks when you hear when
you hear them talking about social
security and you hear the following
words means test so when you see the
riots that were going on in France or 10
years ago they had a thing called
austerity which was riots about people
had we're told they'd be retiring at a
later age before they get their
government pension the pension would be
smaller if you don't have to be
Economist to remember all that happened
10 years ago in Greece and it's
happening right now in France and you'll
hear Social Security means test means if
you have the means to pay you're going
to get less social security or you're
going to have to pay more for Medicare
services so that has been the kernel the
seed that is behind this and now this is
just expanding by the way the reason I'm
doing this is because our government is
we can say bro can we keep raising the
debt limit which is nothing more than
raising the credit card limit on the
United States of America it's from from
unpayable to damn unpayable
and so what New York is doing is just
picking up the same thing they say hey
the United States is broke and some of
you when you are old enough to get
Social Security if you can afford to pay
for other things you're going to pay for
them and you're not going to give you
the Social Security because we're broke
and we're going to give it to the middle
class and these and and people with
lesser capabilities but you people that
are wealthy it'll be a means test you
have the means to pay then you don't get
Social Security or Medicare cost you
more and now they're bringing it over to
parking tickets saying hey wait you know
we got all this uh we have all this
technology what if we find out if the
guy hey he's a 400 000 year banker and
he parked his Mercedes S-Class here and
the meter ran out maybe that should be a
hundred dollars for him not twenty five
dollars and that's what they're doing
ladies and gentlemen welcome to
socialism can I can I ask you a question
though it's okay
so liberals argument I'll give you the
other side of the argument you ready
well who came up with progress wrong who
came up with I'm sorry I jumped the gun
who come up with Progressive taxes who
came up with Progressive taxes
which president which president
who was big on we should we should tax
you know well Ronald Reagan even said we
should tax you know have progressive tax
and we should do this and we should do
that so even your own president was for
progressive tax your your god of
presidents Ronald Reagan proposed this
why shouldn't we have progressive tax
when it comes down to parking fees
electrical bills all these other things
what do you say to that argument well I
didn't support that policy by Ronald
Reagan so I think the response is that
that was wrong you know conservatives
have made mistakes many times you have
to be willing to call out your own side
I mean this is this is just standard
penalization of wealth I don't
understand why anyone who's successful
would live in a place like New York I
cannot imagine why someone like you for
example who's been wildly successful in
business made a bunch of money I can't
imagine why unless you had to for some
business reason you know I lived in New
York City for a long time because I
worked you know in media you had to be
there it was horrible but why would
someone elect to live in a place that
outright comes front and center and
penalizes you for wealth penalizes you
for success as there's a separate set of
standards for you the reason they're
doing this is because there's bolt loads
of people that you know you open up
their glove compartment in their car and
all that comes out are just parking
tickets that have been unpaid and most
of those people are lower income and you
know what they say they say Well they're
not going to come for me because there's
this sense in places like New York City
that they won't come for the so-called
little guy but if you're making you know
400 500 600 000 a year you're successful
oh how dare you so it's just to me
standard well penalization in in in woke
you know Progressive which are you know
basically regressive bastions let me let
me go to the next one which kind of goes
with this Bernie Sanders calls for
confiscation of wealth uh above 9.99 do
you have this clip of Rob while you're
pulling up this not it's on Twitter
leave no emails not millionaires if you
go on Twitter and type in Sanders and
Wallace you'll show just type it on the
Twitter Sanders Wallace and that clip
will show up I'll read the story while
you're looking for it because you know
to stay on this messaging for as long as
you have and people are listening to it
uh do me a favor type in Wallace and
Sanders and then go to videos it should
be the first thing that pops up if you
go a little lower right there click on
that one make it bigger
and play it beautiful
you're saying that billionaires should
not exist so are you basically saying
that once you get to 999 million dollars
but the government should confiscate all
the rest I'm saying that we should go
back to a very progressive tax policy
like what we had on the Dwight D ISO
which would mean that that over a
billion dollars basically it all goes to
the government and you may disagree with
me but I should ask all of it goes to
the government yeah I think people can
make it on 900 you know 99 uh million
dollars you're saying you know he
doesn't say though so your money you're
at 999 million right but now you're
invest now you get the rest is gone but
now you're investing in that money every
single time it drips over they're just
going to keep taking your money is that
what doesn't mean but here's the thing
okay if the government could show
that when the money is given to you you
pay off your debt you're in a better
financial position and you make better
Investments that grow the GDP at a
faster Pace than the private Market can
do well then you have an argument but
you have a horrible resume of this you
know give the money above 200 a billion
dollars to the US government here's what
he says he announces support for
President Joe Biden and called for a
return to a very progressive tax policy
that was like that was under the white
eyes and I introduced new legislation in
April called for the 99.9 percent act
which calls for wealthy heirs to pay
more on their inheritance by expanding
the estate tax to 45
on a state's worth at least three and a
half million dollars it would also
impose a 65 tax on billionaires tax on a
state's worth a billion 65
parents worked hard for this money and
now the government's going to say no no
we did more for you to make this money
than you did give that money to us Tom
what are your thoughts on this argument
with Bernie Sanders because it goes to
me similar to what New York and
California wants to do well I look at it
this way I don't see an argument what I
see I really I don't see an argument you
have to understand where Bernie's coming
from Bernie is not trying to argue about
changing percentages and things in the
structure of the current the current
country they want a restructuring of the
company into a a socialist
socialist construct supported by Marxist
themes that's what they want they want
to wholesale change the country so when
you look at it and you and you sit
inside of a a democratic capitalist you
know freedom and liberty construct and
these people say this to you you say you
people are insane well they are insane
in that argument they're not insane when
they look at their argument and their
argument is say look they're trying to
convert this to a socialist contract
they don't care about the debt they want
the debt to crash the system they want
the outcome of that there's no argument
here that I see what I see is them
slowly pulling the rug out from under
the the construct of the countries we
know it to get to their socialist
Paradigm supported by Marxist themes
that's what I see that's the fundamental
transformation of America that when you
heard Barack Obama talking about in 2008
and people had a really hard time
visualizing what that was this is it and
I think you know these people want
mediocrity they want you know they want
that and they want people who've done
better than that that's correct
mediocrity breeds dependency on the
institutions they love by the way a lot
of these Democrats are very big Pharma
alleys allies it it just it also
encourages people who have been
successful to want to do what pick up
and leave there's so many successful
people now that don't even want to be in
the United States anymore they're like
where can I go because they see that
this is seeping through and seeping
through my two messages to Bernie one is
it's not up to you this is not your
money somebody else has earned this
money it's not up to you to decide if a
million is too much or 10 million is too
much or or a billion is too much it's
not your money hands off people's money
it's not up to you and secondly Pat you
made a great point about you know what
the government does completely and
efficiently with that money you can't
trust that your money's going to be used
well and a lot of times these wealthy
people will donate to charity will do so
much better with their money than
handing it over to government
bureaucracy that does what throws money
at education no results throws money at
the military no results throws money
where what has the government government
done well if you can delineate from me
what the government has done well with
your money then you have an argument
I'll wait there's no and by the way
here's the same guy that used to
criticize Millionaires and billionaires
Millionaires and billionaires
Millionaires and billionaires hey Bernie
you're a millionaire all right
billionaires a billionaire right
billionaires and billionaires yeah stand
by for yeah how would you feel about
your I mean Successful like jet said
you're hitting that billion and all that
money you have no idea where it's going
and then you nailed the jet they're
going to send it to Ukraine they're
going to send it to places where there's
war and like that it's just like
you don't have the money to even open
your mouth it's it's it's unbelievable
by the way jet said something very
important you have no rights on what a
person wants to do with their money stop
trying to make decisions thinking it's
your money and it's your children those
two things leave the children alone and
leave their money alone both are theirs
they've paid a price for it not shoe but
that's the core argument the core
argument is the children are the
children of the State under the
Socialist construct they are there and
you didn't earn that there was a
structure around you and they argue
energy infrastructure sewage all these
things electricity that was there and
your success was based on that so you
really don't deserve all this and it
goes back to Barack Obama you didn't
that yeah you didn't build that by
yourself all right let's go to a
business story and then we'll get into a
couple stories here uh with what's going
on with Tucker so First Republic is
taken over by FDIC and sold to JP Morgan
and third major bank failure in 2023 by
the way last week's story came out their
shares dropped 43
43 but there's a company that's
capitalizing off of this and that
company's name is
JPMorgan so First Republic Bank has been
taken over by federal regulators and
will be sold to JPMorgan making it the
third major Bank to go under in less
than two months within 200 with 229
billion dollars in total assets at the
time of closure First Republic Bank has
become the second largest bank failure
in American history 90 days apart by the
way losing about 40 percent of its
deposit in the first quarter of the Year
amid Rising interest rates and after the
failure of Silicon Valley Bank and
Signature Bank earlier this year causing
a growing cohort of depositors to move
their money to Banks seen as safer and
offering more attractive returns as of
mid-march about 70 percent of First
Republic deposits were uninsured that's
that's a big number meaning they were
larger than 250 000 guaranteed limit the
FDIC estimates the cost of first
Republic receivership will be about 13
million dollars less than the 20 billion
dollars that is estimated at the cost of
Silicon Valley Bank First Republic's 84
branches and eight states will reopen
Monday as branches of JPMorgan Chase Tom
well you know some of you may walk down
the street in quaint little towns and
you'll notice a garage sale and you go
up maybe buy a trinket get lucky find an
old baseball card there uh Jamie Diamond
on the weekend walks down the street and
buys Banks and this Chase
there's First Republic do you take a
check
um the and what is happening here is the
consolidation of of the banking industry
because ever since 2008 the last crisis
things have become more and more lacks
you know you've had a variety of things
that have glass-steagall and other
things that were designed to help it but
now you have Banks failing except the
FDIC think of that as the deductible
like when your car crashes you 500
deductible at the body shop and then the
other guy that crashed into you
hopefully their insurance pays the rest
well the FDIC a little sticker on the
window that says 250 000 deposit think
of that as the deductible but now Jan
and Yellen when svb crashed they created
that new vehicle that the banks can get
their hands on which protects 250
thousand dollars and up so it basically
goes like this it it promotes your
responsibility because now the banks can
be very irresponsible because FDIC will
get part Janet Yellen and treasury will
get the other part and then the bank
will get bought because there's loans in
there there's car loans home loans with
good people and things and JP Morgan
says I'll take those loans over here
I'll collect the interest on them and
I'll help you out and so what is
happening is a consolidation of banking
and then unstable banks are are failing
um this is also is very interesting as
svb and First Republic
JP Morgan specifically Jamie dimon is
trying to walk back into Silicon Valley
to have a foothold there remember it was
2016 he was the first of the big Banks
and he came out in a annual banking
letter and he said listen Silicon Valley
is coming they're smart they're clever
they're going to take away consumer pain
points and they're not going away and
they don't take prisoners so he was
warning the traditional banking industry
of basically the looming fintech and
he's trying to come back in and make
himself
um you know relevant make JPMorgan
relevant three years later he says oh
you know um I just want you know
Chase is not a tourist we're not just
visiting he's not a lecture tour that
we're doing here in Silicon Valley we're
here and we want to do things and so
you're basically seeing Chase
saying it wants to be the biggest and
they're they're not I respect that I do
listen Sandy while uh had a chance when
the whole story when you know uh Jamie
Diamond used to work for Sandy wow Sandy
told Jamie do whatever you want to do
run the company the first thing is Jamie
Diamond does is fires his daughter it's
a very wild story and then the wife says
what are you doing fire your daughter he
said you can't fire my daughter he says
you told me to run the company he used
to be a city guy so everybody knows in
that world if you're gonna talk about
the Michael the Kobe of this era Jamie's
the guy and he's not slowing down
and he's going to be a guy that when
you're thinking about someone's going to
be a you know company to buy everybody
points at Jaime so he's done a great job
you got to give him credit but the
question now becomes
quietly as much as they want to downplay
this how many people are now sitting
there saying listen man I'm not waiting
anymore we're part of a regional we're
part of a community we're leaving just
go to one of the big five this is two in
90 days or 120 days we're not talking
about like 20 billion dollar bank or 40.
these are two 200 billion dollar Banks
we're talking about 200 you know how big
200 billion is if you were to look at
some of the companies that we all know
about Starbucks size if you go to you
know Coca-Cola if somebody's coming how
big are these companies these are 200
billion dollar companies there's not
that many 200 billion dollar companies
that we're talking about Tom who's next
based on this who are they talking about
I've heard couple different names I'm
curious to know who you hearing about
being possible I wish I had the whole
list in front of me but it's basically
there's a variety of lists out there is
and there's some ones that are right at
the top that are stretched on on the
loans they made and
the things that they invested in they
invested some bonds which are now have
moved on the interest rate meaning
picture it this way Banks bought I'll
put it this way for gold for the average
person understand they bought gold high
now Gold's low and they can't have
having trouble selling the gold and
that's supposed to offset the loans they
have so it's like whoops you now can't
sell the gold to pay off all all your
loans or to cover all your loans what's
very there's another very very
interesting thing that's going on in the
middle of this is what you just said Pat
Goldman came out and they had a crappy
earnings quarter but
they had a whole bunch more deposits now
where did that come from of course
Schwab came out and had actually a solid
quarter but they got a bunch more
deposits and Schwab was saying you know
we were very surprised Schwab has a
money fund that's right around four
percent and that's fairly low risk like
the lowest risk you can get is like a
standard money fund four percent may not
seem like a lot until until you think
back that Ma and Pa have been looking at
interest rates of half a percent one
percent or nothing and all of a sudden
money's being moved to money markets
money is being made the movie marketers
say hey Mom Mom and Paul talk about it
they say well at least we can get four
percent and we're not exposed to this
zaniness going on in the stock market so
so here's what's crazy the big guys are
getting the deposits here's what's crazy
you know the the one conversation that's
coming up is a lot about the dollar
collapsing and and people are fearing
could this happen you know since 1450.
can you guess how many different
currencies we've had since 1450 how many
different world Reserve currencies have
we had since 1450 can you name them Tom
I'm Kirsten if you know about this or
not we have a video that's coming up on
this specifically next week well the US
dollar is only since late 40s it was a
huge surge after World War II and it
became the world reserve and I think
before that you had Great Britain pound
okay you got that one and then um at one
point didn't you have the gold back
Spanish real the kings and queens that's
prior so it's Portugal it's Spain it's
Netherlands then France then Great
Britain then it's U.S and U.S some say
since 1921 but it's really 45. so the
concern is is it time for this because
it lasts about 80 to 100 years that's
about the timeline and we've been around
that number right now at about 78 years
1945 we're about 80 years right now so
here's what it's leading to people ask
what should I do you should consider
investing into a non-duplicatable assets
such as What alternative Investments
Masterworks our sponsored today
something you ought to consider doing
art had a record-breaking year last year
in 2022 with all the fears the top three
auction houses had a Rec record breaking
year of 18 billion dollars last year art
alone went up last year on an average of
29 percent and it's been said the last
time inflation was this High
Contemporary Art appreciated on an
average of 20 percent per year from MW
Index this is something you ought to
consider everything they do at
Masterworks is qualified with the SEC
and broken into shares meaning if you
want to buy a bank CA Picasso any of
these things that maybe Warhol you said
I can't afford to buy a two million
dollar piece we can buy a share of it at
Masterworks I think they have over 700
000 users now working with them if you
do want to be invited and join an
exclusive Community Rob let's put the
link below for people to find at
Masterworks you will find a link both in
the chat in the description about
Masterworks this is really great because
you can invest in a Picasso and Picasso
hasn't made a new painting in years yeah
he hasn't made it for years I don't know
why he stopped after he died
I don't know why that happened sometimes
to see somebody using that like as like
a bragging tool like hey you know the um
they're like you oh no no you know that
Red Velvet Rope on that bright buckle
and they're like come on okay so story
came out Chad how bad is it for DeSantis
he's pulling at rfk's level this is a
CNN story that just came out and uh uh
uh Florida Governor Ron DeSantis has
been trying to appeal to his party's
conservative base with moves such as
signing a six-week abortion ban and
fighting with Disney but his efforts
have not paid off from primary
Republican polling a recent Fox News
poll shows him at 21 32 points behind
president Donald Trump incomparable with
19 that Robert F Kennedy uh is receiving
from the Democratic side candidates
polling in the low 20s like DeSantis
have gone on to win with about 20
percent of the time the scientist's
decline is at least in part because of
Trump's rise who has gone from the low
to mid 40s to about 50 percent in the
average 2024 polling the centers please
to the right doesn't line up with where
the anti-trump forces are within the
Republican party which includes a
moderate Wing that is least likely to
want a ban on abortion after six weeks
by the way this is a Fox News poll and
we all know Fox is no longer Trump's
Camp they want descendants so what are
your thoughts on the story you know I I
do think he's in trouble I don't know
you know when you watch his delivery
sometimes I mean he's he's a great
Governor I think we can all acknowledge
that and and rational people will see
what he's done in Florida and policy
wise I think he's on point but I don't
think this is about oh he's not you know
moderate enough there's something about
desantis's delivery I think that is
going to have a hard time translating to
the National stage I think if you have
if you stuck him on a stage today and
you put him and you put someone like a
Donald Trump I think Donald Trump
destroys him absolutely destroys him and
that's not because of policy by the way
I think you know Trump has the he may
step into some potholes here and there
when he talks about you know the uh
vaccine he may stop and to say hey he's
going to get himself into trouble when
he talks about policy and he's also
going to be part of a legacy that people
may reject he also has the January 6th
stuff there's a lot of baggage that he
has but there's something about his
ability to Captivate an audience about
his Charisma about his capacity to own
that stage that DeSantis doesn't quite
have there's something missing there now
also you have this Rift right now in the
Republican party I don't know that the
Trump voters who are really passionate
about Trump I don't know if all of those
go over to DeSantis I don't think that
the DeSantis voters necessarily go over
to Trump so I think this Rift is going
to be an issue I think we're going to
need to like if Republicans want to win
we're going to have to decide first of
all you know is there an official run
here from DeSantis what does that look
like also all of this travel that he's
doing you know this like World Tour that
he did where he's everywhere but there's
no official announcement I think that
rubbed a lot of people the wrong way
people don't understand what his
strategy is is your strategy to be this
fantastic incredible governor in Florida
with a great record is your strategy to
move on to the National stage and I
don't think people know what to do with
all of this chaos right now because if
DeSantis moves out of the way and says
I'm not doing it then I think things
look very different for Trump if
DeSantis is in the game then people have
to start thinking about this differently
I I I don't know what's going to happen
here but he is missing something like
he's missing that star power that you
don't necessarily need as a governor but
you do need on that National stage you
really do it makes a huge difference and
you know you know why you need it I know
you want to say something you know why
you need it here's why you need it so
you don't need it all the time I mean
Biden's got zero star power that's
different but that's what I'm saying to
you but Biden has zero star power right
I think Sanders has star power right if
you think about Bernie Sanders forget
about his policies he's ludicrous but
he's got started right yeah uh Obama
star power oh yeah okay Clinton star
power right you look at John Kerry no
star power right John F Kennedy star
power Nixon no star power you can go
back and say well that's not necessarily
true in the history of all this other
stuff the problem he's facing the guy
that's part of his party that's leading
right now has been a star before he was
born yeah because his mom and his dad
were stars and that you know they were
in the parties they were all so he's
grown up and and in a way it's unfair to
DeSantis because DeSantis has not been
in the you know Limelight Hollywood you
know Stars parties networking charm
Charisma selling all this stuff he's
been more to doer I'm gonna get the job
job done but now when the camera lights
everything is on action you kind of
gotta show up you know and the way it
happened with his books there was not a
lot of performance there Tom yeah I want
to dig in a little bit on what you just
said because it's very interesting you
were saying that thing and I've always
I've sat back and I've always believed
that Bill Clinton could have uh carried
the day on any other president or
candidate including Obama I think
actually he would have been more
tenaciously factually a stronger debate
with with Obama and the American voter
right now kind of short attention span
theater I think we could probably agree
on that and they're easily
impressionable it
DeSantis doesn't have that that Charisma
there that
um
that Trump does the stage presence so
what do you think happens over the
course of the summer you know we've got
a tough economy
the short attention span theater carry
the day on the GOP side or do people
back up and start thinking maybe a
little bit more rationally about
economics and start looking at DeSantis
record I I don't have a bias here I
actually don't have an opinion yet I'm
kind of watching like everybody else but
you dig into it no I I don't think that
that need for the entertainer ever goes
away and I always said this if you're
not entertaining people they're not
listening so you can be a doer and you
can be incredibly efficient and Ron
DeSantis is you know he's that guy that
you hire if you want to get stuff done
right that's great but he's not the guy
you hire if you want to convince people
to vote for him to get that stuff done
so it's I mean and the other option is
you know does this become a team I don't
know they've been taking you know
Trump's been taking a lot of Jabs at
DeSantis but truly if you paired them
then you have the efficiency of a Ron
DeSantis you have the record of Iran
DeSantis and you have the PowerHouse
personality of a Donald Trump that's a
very interesting ticket president yeah
you know you know what Giuliani said it
can't happen because they're both
residents of Florida oh yeah you can't
do that that's right because they're
both from Florida but that's what you
need so like if say it's Trump he needs
to be looking for someone he doesn't
need that big personality he needs
somebody who is a doer in the same way
that Ron DeSantis doesn't need a doer he
needs the personality so that's the
complementary structure that works GOP
voters will not just push to the side
and say oh the economies let me vote
based on issues let me get practical
right now that actually goes very much
against most people's human nature they
want someone who they're going to want
to sit and hang out with and right now
Ron DeSantis is reading a little bit too
much like a politician or a businessman
he needs to read more like someone that
you'd want to have a beer with that's
just a reality you don't have to like
that reality but it is one again
not with but now let me just address
Biden for a second though because you
said first of all it's very different
with Democrats everyone media at large
Hollywood at large everyone rushes in to
help Democrats they actually really have
to be less entertaining and bring a lot
less to the table because they have so
much in their favor but Biden used to be
a funny guy yeah I interviewed him on
the set of the view we had him on he was
funny he was likable I walked away he
whispered in my ear hey don't tell
anyone but I'm a big fan you know we had
a great discussion he was very
charismatic but that and he was that guy
right he knew what to say get a little
grab there too yeah
although there is a picture can he smell
you he smelled her hair out there of him
like leaning in and I'm like and
everybody did memes on that so funny
when he had a person you know he's just
he's not present anymore but he doesn't
need to be Republicans need to be
everything and more right now to get
elected you know I think it is
talking about that missing thing Trump
is a he's not a veteran in military like
the Santa says but he's a veteran of the
media and the gut everybody that that
swamp that he was talking about he's
still in the front lines he fought these
people he won they cheated on him they
he still got there look at all the
those are patriotic he's a gangster look
at those thanksgivings where he showed
up around the world at places those boys
he is a boss he is a leader but but the
scary thing is Jed that look what
they're doing they did all this
investigation all this whatever now
Trump is number one the scientist is
barely hanging on the left we have to
ask ourselves the question why is the
left so uh wanting Trump in there
because they think that they could get
his ass up so so here's here's a uh so
blue auction strategy we just
interviewed the authors for two hours
and we had a very interesting
conversation about ESG Dei if you guys
know about that book I've probably sold
a hundred thousand copies of that book I
love that book if you've never read it
you've got to read it it's the number
one or number two best marketing book in
the history of business books uh behind
tied with Michael Porter competitive
strategy and top 10 best business books
of all time the book sold five and a
half million copies Incredible Book they
got a new book coming out called Beyond
disruption it's a great conversation
everything thing in life you have to
look at yourself as a product your
company your country anything you do is
a blue ocean concept so what can I
compete to do like if you're trying to
date a girl and you're going up against
Larry okay and if Larry comes from a
rich family and this guy's family is
Rich and he's the quarterback and he's
the guy The Jock all this other stuff
but he's really dumb okay but he's
extremely handsome however from your end
you're a competitive swimmer and you
have this and your background is rugged
and you're coming from the streets and
you're kind of like this you can't go
and try to compete with them in an area
that he's got you beat you're not going
to win bro you're just not going to win
okay in the blue ocean concept okay if
we look at America against other
countries so other countries argument
could be like in Iran I'll never forget
when I'm sitting with my mom and my mom
was supportive of Khomeini because the
fear they had is look what Iran's losing
it's losing its conservative values
women are out there wearing this and
they're no longer wearing scarves and
they're becoming hookers and they're
literally one women in Iran were afraid
that by giving too much freedom to women
their daughters could One Day end up
becoming Street girls all this other
stuff so that was how it was sold but
Iran realized you can't sell to women of
Iran you can be free you can do what you
want to do you can do this no we have to
give our argument that's different than
Iran than us because if we talk about
Freedom you're going to lose to U.S
right let's do the sentence against
everybody else here right now okay
Charisma You're Gonna Lose charm you
will lose okay uh policies you will win
okay uh uh leadership and doing it
during covet when it was so nasty you
won't win you will dominate okay when it
comes down to getting into a fight can
you stand up yes uh when you do
interviews and somebody's not in your
ear trying to make you look perfect and
you're just yourself and you're the
tough guy that's going out there and
pushing challenging all that stuff
that's a turn on and you're like here's
what I stand for I think if a marketer
sits down and says dude Blue Ocean
strategy you're not gonna beat him in
this game Ruby and Cruz tried and they
got destroyed so don't try to play that
game but if there's one thing about the
santis if he goes and they push him and
he fights he's in more you know
opportunities to debate somebody
opportunities were to have a banter with
somebody on TV going on CNN going on
MSNBC and there's pushing him and he
comes back and what about this and what
about that and what about this and what
about that I think he wins there because
I think naturally he is a street brawler
but I feel like he's being held back
from brawling I think that is something
that is a strength I think someone in
his ear is not letting bro I think he's
guarded he's very guarded but he has a
likability problem like if you think
about I mean you talked about Rubio and
Cruz River and cruise are not likable
like I don't want to hang out with
either of them you know I don't and I
think a lot of people would probably
find themselves saying the same thing
not that you don't want them to run
something but again I'm talking about
likability can you imagine Ron DeSantis
excelling the way Trump does when Trump
does it goes to a small town and he
walks into the Pizzeria and he's like
hey everyone and he has the pizzeria he
has the bite of the McDonald's hamburger
whatever that is he shines he is a man
of the people in those moments DeSantis
to that he has to be able to do that
though DeSantis has to be able to do
that
he's gonna win an election if he can't
appeal to people in a way that resonates
with so for example you don't like him
story where he came on the tank do you
know that whole story where after that
it was oh do you know the story with
Dukakis and the tank Rob do you know the
story or no just type Dukakis and tank
this is when he was over with Tom do you
want to tell us what the story is about
so Michael Dukakis has to look like you
know a little bit of
a little bit of all America I'm going to
be a commander-in-chief and I'm just a
governor up here and they're criticizing
me for being a brainy little Governor so
what he did was he went out riding
around in this tank taking a tour of a
military facility and Bush remember this
is Bush senior Herbert Walker brush Bush
looks at that and they're like oh this
guy's we this thank you thank you Jesus
destroyed it thank you for this this
picture and everything and he came out
he was destroyed because number one he
didn't look presidential number two he
didn't look like a commander chief he
looked like a geek and and he had he had
let Willie Horton out of jail only to
commit another crime and so his back was
up against the wall and it's basically
he looks like he's from the Middle East
yeah he do that looks like a Taliban guy
no you know he looks like he's he looks
like he's my second cousin or something
like we're related he's in a high school
play about Vietnam this is what this is
but here's the point I'm trying to make
I'm trying to make a point about what
Jed is saying here's here's the point
okay where can the Santa's Excel if he
does videos and clips and things like
that hang out with Navy Seals go to the
military because guess what they know
you go hang out with Navy Seals we all
respect seals you were commander of Navy
SEAL Team go around Navy Seals what do
we think about when we think about SEAL
Team Six what do I think about when we
think about Navy seeds imagine he's
going out there sitting there with 20
other Navy Seals that respect him and
he's talking about the great work that
they do all of a sudden we're like oh my
God this guy's an ABC look he was a
command he wasn't an ABC well he was a
commander an ABCO team there is things
that he you know others cannot do that
you were not an a you were not in the
military so you don't understand I think
the positioning for him if he goes
direct to what Trump naturally has been
doing in New York yep and Nationwide I
think he's gonna get destroyed does he
have to hire a team because you talked
about this on the Giuliani thing about
his marketing team how they weren't
doing a great job especially with the
book making a phone call to Blue Ocean
strategy consultants and I'm hiring them
low-key what was that question go that
line I know where you're going I want to
follow up go yeah so based on the thing
is like Pat you're right now the
sentence I got the Navy SEAL thing thing
but are you going as a right now Pat are
you just getting aggressive and going
out there because yo he has to work out
that muscle Pat that DeSantis has a
little bit of it because I think he got
that from Trump he kind of he kind of
takes his his cues on like how he talks
to the media but he hasn't had that
really fight that that big argument with
any media Outlet where you're like oh
this guy he's good like God so here
here's something that I saw
um the people that have been at school
and served and knew DeSantis from Yale
and from his time as a Jag which was
Judge Advocate General in in the Navy
also the same thing that that get in an
argument with this guy or getting a
debate with this guy let me correct this
first yeah Santa's joined the United
States Navy 2000 I'm promoted to
Lieutenant before serving as a legal
advisor to Seal Team One just just want
to put that out there so everybody knows
go ahead yeah correct he was a Jag so he
was a Judge Advocate which is a lawyer
in the Navy and he was working with Seal
Team one it says you know you can't
prosecute these guys the bad guys
deserved a guy so that's what he was
listening to him for a while yeah but
what he did do you remember when he got
in when he he wasn't so packaged right
now what you're seeing is political
consultants and other people packaging
the candidates and I know Jed's got an
opinion on this and can amplify it she's
got more information I do on this but
the Consultants package candidates the
same way you get packaged and produced
when you're you know uh when you're on a
show on TV do you remember during the
debate why is Florida open what the hell
are they doing down there and they
allowed some of the media to get close
and ask unscripted questions do you
remember what that governor with his
rolled up sleeves from the podium was
telling people no no no no you don't
tell me I'm leading this state and this
is what we're the leader remember that
later that was unscripted they're trying
to pass what you might think you know
the thing is though like what DeSantis
is missing for me and I'm by the way I'm
a fan of his policies I am but what he's
missing is very hard to teach it's very
hard to teach I would rather if you had
to hire me for that role I would rather
have to teach Trump how to change what
he's doing because he's got stuff that's
so hard to teach that Charisma you can't
teach it to Hillary Clinton people live
on the Democrat side have been trying to
teach her how to be likable how to
relate to people there's like a film
over her and and what does Santa's needs
to lose is this politician Vibe he
doesn't read as like a non-politician
that's what Trump has that's why he's
considered a hero to people who believe
in populism I think it's going to be
very hard is that to say that DeSantis
can't overcome it no no but it's gonna
be really challenging for him because I
don't think it's natural for him I don't
think you can hire a media consultant
and by the way most of the times the
people that get hired by these
politicians are people who don't know
how to do media I'm always like I'm like
just hire somebody who understands this
game who gets Charisma they never hire
those people but even if you hired
somebody I think it's going to be really
hard to push to Santas he reads like you
said he's a lawyer for the seals he
reads like the lawyer he doesn't have
that blue collar Vibe and that's really
what most of America is right we're
really just regular people I grew up
behind the Staten Island dump like I
want to feel like somebody gets my
struggle and he's too polished if he can
lose that I think he can climb I don't I
don't think in a year I don't think in a
year Tom that that that's just my
personal opinion but let's not forget we
live in Florida now right we came here
because we heard this guy speaking
DeSantis is Florida famous Trump is
international bro everybody knows who he
is everybody knows the attitude I don't
think I don't think a year is going to
be enough leave him alone and let him be
who he is let America see you said you
said yeah you said Hillary you know and
what Hillary did you know who this Droid
Hillary Clinton's campaign it was Game
Over the day she went on the Zach
Galifianakis show it was oh my God
it's responsible for Hillary Clinton
never remember the president
it was on a dark side
can I email you
Bonnie or die he destroyed her campaign
by the way just something on the Santos
before we wrap up he's got 86 million
dollars waiting for him Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis if he plans to enter the
Republican Prime uh presidential primary
using an 86 million dollar pot of donor
money in a legally questionable way this
is a uh wsj story Wall Street Journal
story if he goes there he has
potentially access to this that's a good
amount of money but Jeb Bush started
with 140 million dollars day one and
he's also not teachable by the way Jeb
Bush I think those are very two
different people that's true I think
those are very few different I look can
you imagine if he can't announce
anything yet until he locks in his
Governor's seat position which I think
he has to wait a week or something like
that to make an announcement imagine him
having almost listened to us or
something he has to listen to all of
this commentary on social on news and
it's he's sitting there saying I'm gonna
kill you guys the moment he's gonna come
out he's gonna be like thank God this
thing is up let me top I'm running this
is what we're doing I mean hopefully he
comes out like that maybe something
shows up
you all like a good fight we'll see what
happened so uh real estate Tom real
quick uh a real estate story uh in
regards to what happened with mortgages
home prices and March posted biggest
annual decline in 11 years biggest
annual decline in 11 years
uh it fell 2.4 in March to an annual
rate of 4.4 million uh marking the 13th
time in 14 months that sales have
declined according to National
Association of Realtors the March drop
follows February's surprise rise of 13
and three quarters from the previous
month to slow down in the housing market
is now affecting prices which fell point
nine percent year on year to median
existing home price of 375 000 folks
there's nothing in Florida south Florida
at 375 this is places like Toledo but
the housing market is slowing down due
to a rise of mortgage rates high home
prices and low inventory levels housing
starts which measure uh U.S Home
Building fell 0.8 percent in March from
February according to a Commerce
Department the number of new listings in
March fell 20 percent year over year
while the inventory of home sales is one
percent higher than in February and up
5.4 percent year over year the cooling
housing market is caused by a cooling
economy the prospect of a recession
within the year the high inflation which
is being fueled by housing cost uh
prices Tom while I'm reading this story
what you know Powell is getting ready to
potentially do something with the rates
what do you know about what he's going
to do is he going to raise rates we're
hearing mixed stories from a lot of
different people what do you expecting
to happen well
um if Kai will get the T-shirt up for
sale we have the 2028. it says fight
inflation save the cheerleader
um
it's um it's it's up there somewhere
Kyle you got to get it into the
storefront on value team at that what
else Tom go ahead keep going so here's
what's happening Powell is coming up I
believe in the next he's heading up the
stairs right now because the FED is
meeting right now and there's going to
be announcements in the next 24 hours
and then also a jobs report by uh Friday
Cinco de Mayo
um in which we're going to hear I think
a quarter point increase and then but
we're also going to hear him say that we
believe we've turned the corner on
things and so there may not be further
increases in June and in July and maybe
when we get toward the end of the year
probably November time frame maybe we
can see the First Rate decrease so that
is what interest rates are looking like
right now that maybe were
um right there on the edge of it now
what does all this stuff mean on the
home prices well that means that
interest rates are still high
people are reluctant to put their homes
on the market right now there's only 980
000 listings available in these United
States nine hundred eighty thousand that
is the lowest it's been in years and
that's resulting in what it says is home
sales have fallen to an average of 4.4
million a year there's about a hundred
million sellable homes in America so
they're saying only about 4.4 million of
those will trade hands in a strong year
it's usually about 10 million trade
hands like 1 in 10. so what do we have
right now
people that have put their houses on the
market the price is still high and
they're reluctant to drop it because no
buyers are approaching so there's no
reason to drop it no other houses are on
the market there's no competition on
their block there's no reason to drop
the price so low inventory gives
consumers few choices and prices aren't
dropping and even if they could afford
it the interest rates on the mortgages
are too high meaning very few
transactions happen and that's what
you're they were talking about here is
U.S home sales fell that's not home
prices folks that's a number of
transactions so your friend who's a
realtor
less work your friend who's a mortgage
broker less work working for a title
company anybody that's in real estate
has got less work and having a tough
time but there's no recession here but
there's no recession no they changed the
definition in real time remember that so
that that's what's going on Pat but
we're gonna see I think uh Jerome Powell
is going to be you know
walking back down those stairs out of
breath on Wednesday afternoon after uh
giving the cheerleader one more shot and
uh Tom do you think even even with all
the stuff that's going on and his lack
of concern for the cheerleader and
with the numbers that they're seeing
Silicon Valley bank and then you know
First Republic how many people think are
calling him saying dude what are you
doing the more you raise the rates
there's more Banks we can't afford it
like how many people think are trying to
get that message across to him of course
we know who's not making that call who
isn't making that call Jamie Diamond I'm
making a call Jamie Diamond is making a
call and saying hey Jerome listen if you
want to raise the rates even more go for
it I will totally support you I
understand it's not fair what's wrong
it's Jamie maybe it's a precaution take
a half point this time just as a
precaution right but but he knows you
know you know who wins the more he
increases the rates the big Banks the
more he increases the rates the more big
Banks win the less he increases the
rates the less smaller Banks win so is
do you think people are making that call
do you think the White House is making
the calls do you think the the chairman
and CEOs of banks are calling and saying
hey can you relate this message to
Powell or I think none of that is taking
place right now I think everybody is
calling there's about uh there's a group
of Board of Governors for the FED that
I'll vote on this but Jay Powell is the
leader and I think you're correct
everyone is calling him and I think it's
going to be a good Cinco de Mayo for one
part and this is what I what I mean by
it I think the jobs report is not going
to be catastrophic but these layoffs are
going to be very real but I think jpeg
towel is going to come out and say this
quarter point and I think we're at a
moderation of inflation I think maybe we
have turned the corner a a a Prudence of
uh of a flat policy over the summer if
he says phrases like that everybody's
going to say oh the worst is over and
you're going to see a stock rally this
week I believe and that ends on Cinco de
Mayo but on Main Street it isn't Cinco
de Mayo yet on Main Street it's still
layoffs housing as we've talked about
and yeah Pat I think there's many
sectors that are out there that wish
look if he wants to if he wants to
really okay we'll use another word here
if he really wants to Goose the economy
um then all he does is he drops things
two points tomorrow morning and makes
cheap money out he won't do it he should
he's not but I don't think that's the
right move I think history is going to
be kind to Jay Powell that he was able
to tame inflation without cataclysmic
unemployment but I think there is going
to be a bit of a recession people are
saying 89 chance you got a Wall Street
Bankers today
86 chance on a wide survey of Wall
Street uh bankers and analysts saying
we're going to have a recession probably
Q4 q1 is what people are are now
pointing to that's all part of getting
through the inflation and getting back
through so here's what here's what
berkshire's Charlie Munger just said he
issued warning for U.S commercial
property uh uh Charlie mcgregates issued
a warning about the U.S commercial
property Market saying that the banks
are full of bad loans as property prices
fall Monger noted that Banks were
already pulling back from lending to
commercial developers and that there are
a lot of trouble Office Buildings and
shopping centers saying there's a lot of
Agony out there Munger also said that
the Berkshire Hathaway had supported
troubled U.S banks in the past and that
it is not that damn easy to run a bank
intelligently there are a lot of
Temptations to do the wrong thing which
a lot of people have done that there's a
300 million dollar building story that
was going out there in San Francisco if
you can pull up the picture here uh it's
a fire sale 300 million dollar building
in San Francisco office tower mostly
empty open to offer offers
but look at that this is on California
Street and you've been to San Francisco
location yep if you can get past the
needles and the feces it's on California
Street and
um the Lobby's beautiful but just
outside the lobby there's a little bit
of a funk little smell but uh if you get
past that this is actually a great
building in what has been historically a
great
um uh commercial address this was worth
300 million dollars in 2019 it's a
22-story building and is expected to
sell 60 million dollars guys from 300
million dollars this is this is Wall
Street Journal story is expected to sell
for 60 million bucks cream of the crop
San Francisco do you know what they're
expecting anywhere between one and a
half trillion dollars to three trillion
dollars high low of defaults in
commercial real estate because they're
about to be called with the new rates
they're not going to be able to make a
lot of these payments so a Class A and
right now the biggest building in Fort
Lauderdale I want to look at it this
week to see if there there's any
interest that one could buy it's the
biggest building in Fort Lauderdale how
many square feet is it we looked at it
it's a 400 000 square feet yeah it's
it's Mammoth we're talking we're talking
multiple partner companies we could have
in there we're talking campus it's huge
it's it's massive 400 000 square foot
building you've seen this building it's
off of federal okay and you know who's
renting nowadays commercial real estate
Class A businesses are not running those
types of offices today it's a very a lot
of things has happened to commercial
real estate the last three days if
there's any sector of the market
specifically real estate that got hit
because of covet it's commercial real
estate you know what is doing well in
commercial real estate industrial
buildings because industrial they need
spaces to go under do manufacturing do
all this other stuff but when it comes
down to the high rises this is going to
be just the beginning guys with cash in
the next six 12 24 months are gonna have
some very very weird opportunities to
buy buildings there's going to be so
many auctions going on right now if you
got cash you could pick up some real
nice properties today specifically in
commercial real estate and I I think
when you look around you sometimes you
can't see what's happening in businesses
but let me tell you this is a strong
economy overall this is the United
States we're not going away and we're
still the reserve currency but I'll I'll
use value payment maybe it's like a
little case study people can't see what
we're doing I mean this what we're
building the company we're building here
and what we're looking for in terms of
space we've tremendous we're running
these conferences we got the conference
team we got the ad team we've got the
media team decentralized media is here
and that is the Bedrock of what we're
growing your podcast is here Jedediah
there are so many things that are going
on so when you hear this there are
companies like us from this world we're
doing in media looking for huge
opportunities and we're about to find
huge opportunities because the
property's on sale to go do the kind of
things that we're already doing and
already in position to do perfect
transition into the story Vice is set to
be headed for bankruptcy May 1st New
York Times story nobody would have
guessed this was coming it was a 5.7
billion dollar company just a minute ago
and now they're talking about going on
auction so Vice media is preparing for
to file bankruptcy after being unable to
find a buyer vice's largest debt holder
Fortress Investment Group could end up
controlling the company in the event on
bankruptcy with Vice continuing to
operate normally and running an auction
to sell the company for 45-day period
with Fortress in a pole position as the
most likely acquired a company which
began as a punk magazine in Montreal
more than two decades ago has blossomed
into a global media company with a movie
studio named Ad Agency glossy showing
HBO and bureaus in Florida and far-flunk
world capitals its investors have
included Disney and fox but a bearish
market for digital media companies and
vices inability to turn a profit has
taken their toll jet thoughts on the
story
did you see Andrew Tate talking about
this online by the way because they did
that documentary on him that guy you
know Matt Lachey or whatever he was was
completely corrupted I mean Total Tool
but you know it's interesting you know
what's gonna happen I guess I guess you
know you look at the if you look at what
Vice has put forth you know for the past
selfies I don't know if any how familiar
you are with bison I've seen the
documentary there's a lot of woke stuff
yeah it's a lot of you know I I think
people are really tired of the messaging
at these locations I think it's going to
be really hard for pretend organizations
as I call them you know Vice was
pretending to be oh we're here to
deliver the news we're here to be
objective we're and when you don't do
that people aren't stupid they look at
that and they say well I'm just going to
turn this off and I think it was really
interesting because Andrew Tate was
front and center that documentary was
front and center and it was garbage I
mean I did it on my show I analyzed it
piece by piece it wasn't it was just a
manifestation of what was going on there
this deception this manipulation of the
public people are really tired of that
stuff I think Disney is suffering big
time as a result of what they're doing
with the wokeness and injected into kids
cartoons and people just want you to be
straight with them if you're a hard left
Progressive as I call it regressive
organization if that's your line if
you're an MSNBC or just own what you're
doing own your agenda I think a lot of
these organizations are getting into
trouble because they're trying to trick
the public oh this is objective
journalism it's not people see it and
then they just say well I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna go here for my information
because now you've been deceptive with
me I can't trust anything you're saying
I think that's been a big part of why
you saw the crumble and I saw just a lot
of celebration of just they feel like oh
fine it's been exposed you know this was
basically a facade for a really long
time I'm not saying they did no good
work but the challenge is when you do
some good work and then in you have
peppered all of this nonsense you ruin
your brand so decide what you want to be
be honest and authentic with the public
and you will receive a good return if
you don't you get this do you think it's
a brand worth buying what they've done
the content anything they have none of
it is worth buying like if you could get
it out of fire sale is it worth buying
I don't know I think I I what why would
you need to buy Vice why why couldn't
you do what they're doing but I I don't
know why you would need to buy it I
can't justify that in the same way that
BuzzFeed I don't know if you saw a lot
of people tweet no should I buy buses
yeah no I wouldn't suggest that why do
it better why do you need to buy that
entity that's already failed and that's
I mean I don't Tom what are your
thoughts on this uh I I tend to agree
and then I see another side of it too so
I'll take take a counter side I I looked
at some of these announcements today on
Vice and what I did was I just kind of
looked at it through the lens of Twitter
so a large debt holder Fortress comes in
and then everybody else has to stand to
the side kind of like Elon Musk coming
in buying Twitter and then there's a
bunch of stuff going on inside here that
is not profitable they shouldn't be
doing and you immediately cut that the
same way that uh Elon Musk said hey
these 10 projects over here for
technology I'm cutting them I'm still
working on this stuff over here all you
people wait another group on censorship
okay you're gone too and by the time he
was done he only had 20 percent of the
people left and guess what Twitter works
really really well right now still and
you know blue checks and all the other
stuff is done you can debate that if you
will but he's showing that the company's
actually growing Twitter is growing and
from a pruning to growing and so I look
at this and I'm like wow you know we got
a movie studio we got this and this and
this and this and this what if somebody
comes in like Fortress because Fortress
has said we're going to continue to
operate normally while we're running an
auction process and I think what will
happen is Fortress has to look at it
through two ways one I'm going to end up
like a PE firm I'm going to end up
owning this son of a and now I'm
going to be stuck with it so what are
they going to do they're going to be
doing layoffs and trimming things seeing
it do it so I see like a Twitter
comparison where Fortress might end up
running Vice light only some things that
are actually you know profitable and
worthwhile now that said I was also
reading a media that said there's not a
lot of consumer connect to the vice
brand they don't have stickiness across
everything they're just present and it's
one thing to be present like you know
like you know a channel on TV
um like the USA Network you're kind of
present but there's no real stickiness
to the USA Network you know what I mean
that's right that's you're right and and
also don't you think I mean see to me
the comparison to Twitter is interesting
but Twitter was sticky Twitter was a
place it had its flaws I can understand
somebody going in like an Elon Musk and
wanting to buy Twitter because even
though it has its flaws there was so
much good about it it was so much hot
about out it was so sticky so much so
that even people who couldn't stand some
of the censorship that was happening and
some of the nonsense that was happening
in the last two years still couldn't
take themselves off of it right you're
like addicted to it because there's
something really cool and interesting
and energy energetic about it Vice isn't
that it's just kind of existing and for
me Vice feels very much like corporate
media right now it's there it's
happening but why would somebody go in
if you had the power your pbd right you
have the power to go in and say okay I
can buy this why would you buy that you
can do it better yourself anybody who's
gonna have the power to buy that is
going to have the power to do it better
without any of the tainted nonsense that
comes with the baggage of that
organization that's that's what I love
what you said too Judd you said uh own
your agenda at least be honest if you're
honest you'll work if you're if you're
full of people great line I love on
your agenda on your agenda put it on a
shirt no that's yours that's all you so
don't shoot me pbd but I I'll say this
out where's the gun no I'll say
you know I I took the call today for
valuetainment because they know that
we're capable and I spoke to an analyst
at uh I can say this one I can say this
one not the second one oh you can give
the first one not the second one um I'll
give neither one but I spoke to two
analysts and both of them are like hey
you know um you know Fortress is looking
for potential you know acquirer Partners
you guys obviously have the capability
you know uh two weeks is there going to
be a package out on this and I'm like
absolutely we'd like to look at it we'd
like to look at it but you know we're on
to your point we're on the list and we
could do this and the question is you
bring up a good point why would you how
come you don't put Vinnie and I on the
call on the acquisition yes please
serious I think that would be great well
listen I didn't want to be in public but
that's the final question
you know what I want video on it with
these analysts
I've got corporate Council on here you
could record that can you imagine oh my
God yes yes what's up
I got your habeas corpus right here but
you know the one thing that is going on
the one thing that is going on that
there's no question about
there is a massive shake-up disruption
going on in media as an industry as a
space right now huge whether it's people
questioning fake news whether it's some
people transitioning out whether it's
Rupert Murdoch wanting to go to a
different direction whether it's you
know CNN and and Malone's saying we're
done with Don Lemon and you know whether
it's you know Vice whether it's BuzzFeed
there's a there's a lot of this stuff
that's going on right now and and you
know even Disney is kind of a packaging
ESPN to you know in a quiet way to say
ESPN could be for sale for the right
number there's a lot of shake up going
up right now and let's talk about Tucker
obviously at this point of the game
we hear the stories with what's going on
with Tucker Tucker's video was posted I
don't know how many views I got at this
point if it's shy of 100 million I
wouldn't be surprised if it isn't the
world has seen Tucker's video the
message that he gave and if you speak
sign language you understand what Tucker
was talking about when his code language
you understand what Tucker was talking
about and recently just recently I think
even yesterday a leaked video derides
Fox streaming service okay if you've
seen this clip this video of Tucker that
everybody is playing and and we've all
seen it everybody's seen it at this
point you know I I don't want to be a
slave to Fox Nation which I don't think
that people watch anyways we're gonna
because you know I'm a like a
representative of the American Media now
speaking to an exile in Romanian
welcoming him back into Brotherhood of
journalists you know and he's you know
this is a Carlson says on a video
footage from 2020 to leaked to Media
Matters I wonder who from Fox News
leaked into Media Matters where Media
Matters can't stand Fox News but
nobody's going to watch it probably from
Fox Nation nobody watches Fox Nation
because the site sucks so I'd really
like to just adjust and put the dump the
whole thing on YouTube Carlson was
apparently speaking to representative
for internet personality Andrew Taylor
was recently detained a Romania on
charge of human trafficking anyways
there's a lot of different things that's
going on with Tucker Newsmax is at the
front Rumble is saying they may do
something with it there's talks about
Rumble could be doing some kind of stuff
with Tucker jet you've been in this
world you you speak very very highly of
Tucker the other day we're having dinner
you were telling me he was one of the
smartest guy you ever worked with you
told us that's when we're having dinner
what can you say about what's going on
and where do you think this guy's gonna
end up
I mean he's Tucker is a rock star right
Tucker is one of the people that you
actually work with and you know that he
believes what he's saying that he's
committed to principle that if he makes
a mistake and get something wrong he's
going to say it which is so incredibly
rare in media Tucker is going to be a
rock star no matter what he does uh I
think he's going to go off and do
something on his own he may start a
company of his own he will get his voice
and his content and his message out to
people so I think people could rest
assured that he's not going away anytime
soon I think his video that now I think
has almost 80 million uh reach I think
expressed that he's also laughing about
these leaks I mean this is very
predictable when you work in corporate
media they they very obviously fired him
they very obviously silenced him over at
Fox he was very clearly having editorial
conflict with senior leadership and just
wasn't going to sit down and shut up I I
actually watched that leak video and I
liked him more because it was just him
being him they think they've got stuff
on this guy and what they don't realize
is that what people really love about
him is that he wasn't playing the game
and that he was on the inside fighting
the this censorship and fighting this
you can say this but you can't say that
and fighting this you can you can do
these topics because what happens is
there are Untouchable topics in
corporate media so you do have some
freedom to move left and right but
you're still in a straight jacket you
can't touch this you can't touch this
and if you do and if you you know go
against the powers that be you either
lose your job or you have to leave or
you have to negotiate and exit that's
what happened here I don't believe for a
second that this is about some little
internal text messages or nonsense like
that they were looking for a reason to
get rid of this guy because this guy
wasn't playing ball the way they wanted
him to play ball so I think it's really
interesting you're going to see more of
these leaks you ask you know who's
responsible for the leagues the senior
leadership there knows this is happening
they're probably authorizing it in many
ways they love it they think they're
going to have the power to wreck this
guy and they don't they also if you've
seen the ratings the writers are
destroyed over there they're destroyed
because people and it's not just about
Tucker yes Tucker was a rock star you
can't just replace Tucker with somebody
but also people are so tired of being
lied to they're so tired of being lied
to and they know that when they watch
these networks your these people these
individuals these Talking Heads are
called Talking Heads or reason I was
there I know the restrictions that were
placed on me again you have a little bit
of flexibility but not a lot they know
that they're not getting the real truth
they know they're not getting the real
story they know that people are Cowtown
to Avatar advertisers and you know
Pharma and and corporate you know
lackeys at the top and they don't want
to watch that anymore when they can
watch stuff like this we're just sitting
here having a conversation they can go
on Twitter they can go on sub stack they
can get real citizen journalists and get
to the truth of the matter so I think
Tucker has a career no matter what I
think he's a rock star no matter what I
think he's completely irreplaceable in
that slot by the way do you think he's
multi-dimensional meaning he can do
podcasts show when I started and the
reason why I'm asking this question is
because because you know when you talk
about Rogan I can't ever see Rogan being
put in a box and saying here's a six
writers for you they wrote what to say
and go do this I don't think Joe I think
Joe would be miserable doing that I
think to me Tucker is a multi-faceted
talent that wherever you put him he's
going to be able to do it Tucker is a
media Savvy star and I remember coming
into this business I wrote for him over
at the Daily Caller for a little while I
worked with every time I worked and we
worked on red eye together we would sit
he's he's spontaneous he's full of
Personality Tucker has that thing that I
talked about before by the way that
Rhonda Sanders doesn't have when I'm
talking about that thing it's it the it
Factor he has it and I always spoke
highly of him when I first and I know
there are some people at Fox by the way
um in very high level positions who were
highly responsible for Tucker's rise
that probably are rolling over now like
they don't know what to do because they
know his power and they know his talent
and they know his capability but they're
fighting the internal machine they have
no they really have no power at the end
of the day day but he is that guy I
think you can stick him in a cable news
setting you can sit him in a network
network TV setting you can sit him in a
speech you can sit him on a stage you
can sit him in a conversation like this
yeah he can just roll this is his thing
because you know why he's just him he's
not afraid to just be him to be silly to
say I don't know I think I screwed up to
get on stage and say something that say
I'm not an expert at that people are
dying for that so I think he he goes I
think this only grows whatever he plans
to do he will be making more money and
reaching more people post box than he
did while he was there people come a
media personality and I kind of disagree
with that I think he's a media leader I
look at what he did at Daily Caller and
look what he did on his own show I mean
he's a he's not just a leading voice
he's a leading thinker and he's a leader
he's a media leader and so wherever he
goes you know if I was sitting there
yeah I'd be sitting there saying where
can I really lead where can I be more
than just this because I don't think I
mean if he went someplace like Sirius
for the the Howard Stern contract that's
one dimensional
you want 10 producers there's 10
producers 120 writers there's 20 Riders
now go just go sit and do your do your
show Stern
that that worked I mean for for Sirius I
got the subscribers they wanted kind of
but that's that's so one-dimensional
this guy is so much broader I I believe
he's a media leader and I think he's
going to land on his feet someplace that
gives him that platform and that canvas
to be a full person he also Tucker
hosted I hosted a show called Fox and
Friends Weekend for a while
um Tucker hosted that show before I got
there he was the guy on the show he was
fantastic he gave that show life he was
the reason I wanted to take the job
because I was very hesitant to take that
job for many reasons but I was like oh
man look what he did with it you know
and you get there and you realize that
you've been watching that show with
Tucker on it and then you're part of
that show without Tucker and it was
missing Tucker you know he's the kind of
guy that comes into a room and you
really just feel like wow this is
whatever we do here is gonna be great
because he's part of it so and and you
know this isn't about whether you agree
with him on everything this is about a
guy who was telling you the truth who
was uncomfortable sitting the behind the
veil of corporate media manipulation and
censorship and that's a beautiful thing
a beautiful thing you know I I would uh
say a couple things when you look at the
viewership they showed so Megan Kelly
showed this on her message I'm sure on
her video how his episode last Thursday
was uh two point okay Tucker's finale
was 2.65 million at the 8 PM Eastern
Standard Time Monday was 2.59 he wasn't
on Tuesday 1-7 by Wednesday half the
audience left okay literally half the
audience left by Wednesday okay and and
it's got to be very hard for the person
that replaces Tucker okay and obviously
look who tweeted that with the data
Brian stelter
honestly his show never did the 0.33 or
whatever the side is yeah so Brian is is
uh you know went from and now he's
talking about the fact that Don Lemon
and Tucker are texting each other and
you know imagine what could happen if
they have a show together the two and
and obviously Megan made a very good
point Megan's like I don't think Tucker
would ever reach out to Don Lemon lemon
is the one that's probably reached out
to him because he shared a lawyer
whether whoever reached out to who or
not it's irrelevant Tucker's number one
period so it's not like you know Tucker
needs lemons advice lemon needs Tucker's
advice and it's good for lemon and you
know to talk with Tucker on what to
do I remember the first time we started
this
uh when Mario says hey let's start
creating content we bought a
teleprompter do you know how long how
many times I used a teleprompter for 30
seconds
they put the teleprompter there and and
within 30 seconds I'm like
I take this thing out of here I mean we
lost money on the telephone we bought
the nice fancy not the iPad teleprompter
yeah we bought the full-blown
teleprompter thinking it's gonna be I'm
like I can't so so to maybe put it back
in the Box try to return it but it was
already broken no nobody else already
broken nobody could there's a very
there's only a few people that can do
what Tucker does and matter of fact at
his level he's number one let's put him
up there do you think because here's the
here's the conversation when Bill
O'Reilly left no one's going to replace
Bill O'Reilly everybody said this oh
it's gonna be done game over making
Kelly oh nobody it's just it's done it's
over Tucker Carlson oh well it's done
it's over what is different Jed about
Tucker than when it happened with Megan
then when it happened with O'Reilly I
don't know that it's Tucker I think it's
the time and I think it's the awareness
that people have of what corporate media
is and I think it's the options that
they have so it was a time where you
didn't have a lot of options you turned
on the TV that's what you saw people
would I mean I know like my parents even
old school put the TV on you watch the
news you shut it off that's your option
now with podcasting is what be what it
is with Twitter streaming with Rumble
with VT with all of these options people
are now seeing what corporate media is
so it's not just a rejection of like oh
hey you can't just replace Tucker in and
expect me to be a drone and keep the TV
on it's not just people saying that but
it's them saying I know that you're
misleading me I know that I'm not
getting an authentic experience here I'm
tired of it that people weren't that
tired and weren't as informed of how
horribly censored this stuff was when
Megan Kelly left when Bill O'Reilly left
so you know I think it's just a
different time I think they're playing
with fire I think corporate media
doesn't really understand that these
people that are now on Twitter that are
on social that are in sub stack that are
they just know what you're doing they
don't need you anymore they don't need
you and they count on by the way the Fox
News of the World the ABC and by the way
you know this is go this is not just
about Fox News ABC sensor that RFK video
I don't know if you you saw they put a
big disclaimer give me a break if you if
you were so confident debate the guy no
you don't have the facts so you've got
to censor them it happens all the time
that's like the view screaming at me oh
misinformation really you didn't have
the facts honey or you would have let me
say my piece and you would have said
yours so I think there's just a deep
awareness now there's a rejection of the
same Fox is counting on people just
leaving their TV on like oh they'll get
over this yeah I I just I don't think so
I think your time is coming to an end
where you think it's coming to an end I
I agree I think Fox is changing
drastically I think when they did that
segment about you know the trans stuff
as it related to kids and it was like a
celebration day people were like on Fox
News I think there's been a lot of
censorship I think there's been firings
that people have noticed wait a minute
these are free thinking people that no
longer have a home I think their brand
is changing I think someone may may make
a purchase of that brand at some point
Fox is not the fox of 10 years ago and I
think even the older audience to me my
parents even you know it's funny I left
Fox this is people laugh about this but
I left Fox and even occasionally they
would still put the TV on what were they
watching though Tucker Tucker Tucker
because it was like the last Bastion of
a guy who wouldn't play ball the way
they wanted him to play you know you
know what's crazy is right now there's
talks that Maria barturomo's next and
judge pirro's yeah that those
conversations are being thrown around
left and right and and everybody is you
know sitting there wondering if there's
going to be a decision like this be made
here's my thing here's here's a question
I have a conversation with somebody this
weekend and I I may be making a very
strange announcement sometime today
weird announcement bold announcement on
behalf of entertainment so stay tuned
Megan Kelly today at one o'clock I may
announce it on Megan Kelly today at one
o'clock when I talk to her uh but but
here's the thing here's the one thing I
think about we were having dinner if
it's it's me you Tom Vinnie and this guy
what's his name this good looking guy
he's the second best looking guy in the
building
he's the muscular bodybuilder hunk which
we gotta have you ever put his picture
up do people know what he used to do
yeah
I will maybe on the next episode show
what Jeremy looked like okay so anyway
here's the Whisperer so we're having
dinner we're having dinner and I ask you
a question I said I said do you know I'm
talking to this guy I said do you know
who Stefan Marbury is most people don't
know who Stefan Marbury is but Stefan
Marbury at one point was top three best
guards in the NBA the guy was ridiculous
if you tape on type type in Stefan
Marbury and go to his stats just go to
his stats uh if you go a little lower
you'll see what the stats so Stephon
marby was playing in the NBA right there
right to click on that and if you go
little Lord to show his stats zoom in a
little bit right there zoom in a little
bit to show what his numbers were okay
if you look at the right side points per
game look at that points per game 23.4
22.2 23.9 20 22 20 20. this guy was an
incredible player in the league but
something happened he started having an
attitude
and all of a sudden one of the teams
said you know what we're gonna pay you
but we're gonna bench you and we're
gonna take away the best years of your
plane years away from you and then I
posed a question to you guys and I said
do you think Fox is sitting there saying
our agreement we will continue to
fulfill Our obligation of what we have
to pay you the remaining whatever time
is left on the contract the year two
years
but you can't go anywhere and you can go
somewhere two years from now where we're
going to continue paying you and then
everybody had a different opinion to say
well you know this this that and you
know all this other because typically
somebody can come and buy that contract
out from another team the team that
Marbury was playing for they're like no
we're not even selling the contract this
guy didn't play his best for us and
we're paying the money they're paying
them six and eighteen million a year
you're not even going to get any playing
time do you think Fox at all any
percentage that the strategy Fox is
playing right now is to keep them
benched for as long as possible to hurt
Tucker Carlson do you think that's what
a strategy Fox may be playing today I
don't think it's to hurt Tucker Carlson
I think it's to keep him quiet through
potentially through maybe the next
election cycle I mean this guy is in
danger this agenda goes really deep this
isn't just about Tucker this is about
what Tucker's talking about this is
about what he's putting from Center yeah
so there was always this idea that you
know if you were battling the system you
were battling the left left versus right
that is not what happening that is not
what's happening these are regular
people who care about their freedom
battling the system some people call it
the system some people call it the
Matrix corporate media is that system
it's the censorship system it's the be
quiet sit down shut up do what I tell
you and there's so many Talking Heads
willing to play by that game so it's
it's less about Tucker It's about what
Tucker was shining a light on it's about
the powers that be that the people at
Fox answer to who's their boss who are
they getting messages from so they
report to but you think there is a
possibility that they're mentioning
between yeah I do think that well right
now especially now because they are
negotiating now typically what will
happen is there's two options either
they're going to bench him the full
duration of that contract and he's going
to get paid but he's not going to be
able to go anywhere which is a horrible
thing to do or they're going to
negotiate and exit and they will have to
do some type of payout but he will have
freedom to go find another position or
do whatever he wants and once he starts
that then he will no longer get paid by
Fox News but I did I mean they lose big
time if they silence this guy long term
if they make a decision that they are
gonna cave to whoever they answer to in
the system and we know there are people
you answer to if they make that decision
people are going to be aware that
they've they've silenced this let me
throw a crazy thing out there crazy
thing out there and if there's anybody
qualified to speak on this guy's jeded
that I just crossed 200 000 Subs if
you're supportive or message let's get
that channel and her voice to a million
Subs as soon we may even put a party
together and do a jet event at 500 000
subs and we'll make some announcements
on that what jet is up to but Jed
there's two guys you speak about a lot
one is a guy named Andrew Tate which I
don't know if you've heard of this guy
before he's a very loud guy and another
guy named Tucker Carlson is it fair to
say you respect both of these guys yes
okay so
I just got word from uh uh uh uh Andrews
Camp literally right now the text just
came in and the text says the appeal
against the house arrest extension was
rejected today again so the boys will
remain under house arrest until the end
of May so here's another one that
they're doing the last one they can do
this on is June I want to jump on a call
with these guys right after this right
after I'm done with the Dream Team call
so
um
okay I'm having a conversation with
their camp
and the concern is every month Romania
extends this delay more and more and
more and more and more the red pill
community
that you know talks about what they talk
about the cream of the crop at the top
of the Red Bull Community is one guy
right now it's Andrew Tate okay when
he's out there everybody's doing what
they're doing and you know you're you're
able to drive that and I think Tucker
kind of plays to that at the cream of
the crop of his space today where
Tucker's at and where Tate is at right
how crazy of a ideal would it be that
those two names would be the two names
that we don't want to do a lot of
talking right now for them to stay quiet
are you going in a direction where the
same way Romania is kind of maybe if
there isn't anything because every month
is allegedly allegedly allegedly there's
nothing yeah no charges at all do you
think there is really the crazy strategy
that the people that are the leaders of
the Matrix are trying to silence a
Tucker and a Andrew Well if there's a
possibility of that of course I mean
these are two guys that again they're
not playing ball they they refuse to be
silenced I mean you see Andrew Tate he's
under house arrest but he's tweeting
he's reaching so he's reaching more
people on Twitter than people on cable
news who get on TV every day get their
hair and makeup done and put on a big
show so they're still powerful and if
you don't think that folks in the system
the powers that be are looking and
saying we try to take this guy out he's
he's not even able to go do interviews
yet or anything for you know probably
legal reasons and look at his reach
Tucker Carlson puts a tweet out and it
reaches more people than the guy who was
hosting in his old time slot on a Cable
News Network that is the leader in cable
news so of course they want these guys
silenced they and and what's deeply
threatening about the Andrew Tates and
the Tucker Carlsons is that when you
take something away from them you know
putting Andrew Tate in jail look what
you took away from him a lot he was away
from his family sitting in a jail cell I
mean this is not this is not easy for
people to go through you look what you
take away from Tucker Carlson amazing
platform you take something away from
them and they turn around and they say
I'm not being quiet Andrew take come out
just as controversial saying what needs
to be said in the same way as before
Tucker Carlson puts a video out after
being fired and silenced talking about
silencing they're not messing around you
cannot shut these guys up that is the
golden ticket so they will continue to
be influential and do I think the system
is targeting both of them 100 do I think
the system's gonna win nope no way we're
on the same page
and you know there's there's two sides
to this there's the there's the
censorship and the messaging and playing
ball side that
um Judd's talking about and then there's
also the legal side and the legal side
has been a a river of failures every
time people have tried to block block
people and one of the things you can go
back and look at is um a lot of You Are
not old enough to remember but when
Letterman and Leno they were both under
the property of NBC and NBC decided
we're gonna Johnny Carson's retiring and
we're gonna put Leno in The Tonight Show
uh Letterman was at the you know 12 30
time slot The Late Show with David
Letterman and it was um
you know Letterman said I think I earned
that chair I earned the 11 30 chair
Johnny Carson's chair and they said well
no we're going to keep you on your on
your contract and Bob Wright and Warren
Littlefield completely fumbled it and
Mike Ovitz put together a counter offer
that that delivered
um their position and that's how CBS got
Letterman and put him in the 11 30 times
and for the next five years Crush Leno
and ratings and this is the legal side
folks there is always a way out there's
it's just like Fight Club there's always
a way out just on the legal side but now
in the modern time you also have this
other side where you have this this you
got to play ball with our message and
there is we can go down the rabbit hole
even further to what I believe is a you
know a single party system in the United
States with two kind of colors in it
rather than really a two-party system
you're talking my language won the UNA
party time you're getting me very very
excited here talking about the unit
party I'm just no but I I'm saying you
can go back and look at this and so you
know it's not the contract that the P
that they're going to have trouble with
the contract is extricatable very
extricatable
um the the issue is they don't want the
voice out there to compete with their
programming but at the end of the day
they got to make a buck and right now
um they are not making a buck and they
are slipping and if they're just waiting
for the smoke to clear to come back
there's nothing there on the plate that
people find appetizing at Fox what you
once were you have given up you're not
there anymore
and that's why decentralized media is
where it's going to large corporate
media is is not just dead it's in
hospice and those that are still alive
are in hospice and are dying but you
just don't see it the opportunities
tomorrow is in decentralized New Media
that is distributed in new and different
ways ladies and gentlemen and you got to
thank God for like Elon Musk imagine if
he didn't buy Twitter Jet and there was
still all that censorship with the FBI
and everything you wanted to hear none
of these guys speak Rumble and all that
I mean all those other like what's that
troop social now but the ritual dude
thank God for Elon Musk man oh my God I
tell you Spotify which by the way he
made a very strange announcement
recently saying we will promise to not
make any major offers anymore uh uh uh
he said this from Spotify I think
Spotify
Rumble you have to give credit to what
rumbles when they're playing a very
important role Twitter credit to uh What
uh was doing Fox screwed up because Fox
was also one that was at least Tucker
was there to can talk and say the stuff
that he was saying but those guys play
very important role with what's going on
today let's go to the next story uh a
few things with
um Sanders talking about Biden you guys
saw this last week with the White House
Correspondents Dinner a bunch of
different things was said you know the
jokes you know I I actually thought some
of the stuff that was written the
writers were good at that I I you have
to give credit to the writers on what
they said but Biden joked about his age
needing a helmet for DNC events amid
report on his declining work hours
finally he just wasn't like holding back
you know if he's going to be running
again he'll be an 86 year old president
you know you know some of the jokes were
you know I promise you I'm working like
hell to get home you know a bunch of
other things you know one of the things
he said he says look there's a lot of
media companies here CNBC is here the
owners of CNBC the owners of this and
the owners of Fox Dominion is here you
know these things when he said it was
actually funny so credit to the writer I
thought that part was funny now at the
same time there was a Bernie Sanders
came out and says Biden could win in a
landslide okay Senator Bernie Sanders
said Biden who kicked off his
re-election campaign last week could win
in a landslide in 2024 given a current
political backdrop of a major political
party the Republican party where many of
the leadership doesn't even believe in
democracy Sanders stressed that he
thinks Biden is the Clear Choice for
voters and if Democrats on the president
get stronger on working-class issues and
take on the greed of the insurance
companies working class he believes
Biden's going to win a landslide Sanders
waved off concerns about Biden's age and
stressed that what voters have to look
at is what does the candidate stand for
which side are they on Jed when you hear
a story like this do you agree with
Bernie Sanders that Biden could win in a
landslide I do I do think he could win I
think people need to be prepared for
that um and I did I said this last time
in fact we had a a debate in my house uh
my parents are you know different
degrees of conservative but they were
like oh there's no way there's no way
Biden's gonna win I said he's going to
win what mark my words he is going to
win and he did and I think people need
to be prepared because corporate media
wants Biden to win and by the way that
includes Fox News they want button to
win they they do better when they're
going against Biden that that is their
business model that's how it works
um corporate media wants Biden to win
Hollywood wants Biden to win the
entertainment business at large wants
Biden to win the system wants Biden to
win
um Biden has a lot of very powerful
people in his corner I think when you
couple that with the fact that the
Republican base is so split right now
between DeSantis and Trump as we talked
about before I think there are
weaknesses big weaknesses in both of
those candidates and I think you have
obstacles like young female single
voters they're not voting Republican
it's not happening they're looking for
Big Daddy government to be what you know
they're missing male head of household
used to be I know I'll get he for that
but it's true and you have a growing
segment of the population that wants
something for nothing they want
something for nothing and you have a lot
of people in this country now that are
deeply compliant that prefer for the
government to tell them what to do for
than for them to figure out how to do it
themselves do you have freedom lovers
yes do you have increasing number of
people who aren't that way yes so do I
think Joe Biden could win a landslide
yes I think that's a sad reality that
people should start to wrap their heads
around and I do believe by the way the
bigger fight and the more worthwhile
fight is in local politics is in
community politics go find set yourself
up somewhere city state that you feel
supports and protects the values that
you believe in and those are the votes
that matter more than these National
actions so yeah
I I would not be surprised so are you
are you saying you may run for something
can you imagine me running back
I actually can you you'd have my vote
Tom thoughts on this Tom's gonna be my
running mate you're going to be the
me and Tom that could be so Chet what
are you gonna do with the economy Tom
Tom
you have to do the bill you have to be
Bill Clinton
I think we've got a plan for the economy
lead this country in ways that you don't
understand I would vote you guys got my
voice hang on hang on a second tall
crown and water remember the line the um
so what I think is going on here is
Judge Wright you know if this is
misplayed by the GOP this could be a
Biden land side but that's not going to
be a Biden lad Side by decision it'll be
by default here's what I mean by that if
the Republicans don't put together a
compelling case and a compelling
candidate served up in the right way
then it's going to look confusing and if
it's a bloodbath in the primaries and
everything kind of goes Haywire then
there's nothing for the voter to really
latch on to then you'll have a Biden
Landslide by default meaning there's
nothing for there's nothing to move that
10 12 percent of the independent voter
in the middle which is what the election
all national elections now hinge on so I
think it could happen but they've got to
get their act together now and make a
compelling case on the candidates and
not over package candidates and let them
be themselves because I think there's a
candidate in there the voters are going
to love and they're going to see the
contrast and they're going to want a
difference and it's going to be Stark
but if that gets fumbled then you'll get
a you'll get a Landslide by default not
because they love it but just by default
because the 10 12 of The Independent
middle aren't going to move but just it
blows my mind though that that
independent 10 15 12 cannot just look at
what the hell's going on nothing is
going right I don't care how you see it
where you left the right how how like do
you think that the uh their whole
abortion stance that that can sway the
election one way or the other well I
think again you have those like young
female it's a very important voting
block people always underestimate that
young single woman that's who hears
these the wokeness who hears the
platitudes Biden talks in these like
ridiculous platitudes like he's
promising you the Sun the moon and the
stars who who's receptive to that you
have to be an emotional voter to be
receptive to that you have to be willing
to be the exact opposite of what Tom was
describing Tom was asking before well do
you think that you know voters are going
to be more practical that they're going
to look at the economy and they're going
to be able to get past character no the
emotional voters looking at oh that was
a mean tweet I can't go for him I'd
rather vote for this guy over here who
told me that there's leprechauns and
rainbows you know I want that that makes
me feel good about myself it's about
feelings not about actually benefiting
from policies yeah what's Vinnie what's
this video what is this so this is this
is Trump listen I laughed so as a
comedian this is he's up there and he's
talking about how Joe Biden talks and
doesn't know where the hell he is I saw
the one where they split it where he
actually saw the video of Biden but this
is one of the funniest this is Trump is
back and he's in full force and he's
talking crap go ahead rob you got to
show this do you think at least one time
you get up and say I'm running for
president uh where where am I going
where the hell
no over there
dude
that's the it that's the exactly he's
talking
yo a pre-packaged video
that took supposedly seven takes to get
it right if right is what you want to
call it oh man
in it he says he's running because Trump
and Maca pose a threat to democracy can
you believe it do and and like come on
Pat that's what you mean you can't teach
that yeah exactly he's an entertainment
he did that off the cuff he didn't plan
that he just in his Trump World said you
know what I'm gonna go for it are you
more likely you know into the people
watching at home right now are you more
likely to watch a debate if Trump is in
it or if Trump is out let's say you know
half the debates have Trump in and half
the debates have Trump I guarantee you
the viewership takes a nosedive just
because people find this so entertaining
it's like watching a television show
unfold and he's totally on rehearse I
love you can't teach it I love it by the
way also Newsmax
um has seen when we were talking about
Fox News before Newsmax has seen some
Rises interestingly enough at this time
whether or not they can sustain it Eric
the 3x yeah I was on with Eric last week
um very interesting um to see what
happens with that as well from 180 to
589 wow from 180 for eight o'clock he's
eight o'clock right what is there from
122 to 5 62. one two even more than I
said it's like 5x nearly four and a half
X because there is an age bracket of the
population that's very used to that like
my dad he watches he's watching right
now but you know he doesn't understand
hi Tony very conservative but he you
know they don't understand all the inner
workings of this new media and they're
used to click the TV on they'll change
the channel though they'll stay within
that Forum maybe but they'll change the
channels by the way did you did you see
uh one of your favorite people in the
last three years fauci did you did you
see uh can you can you go to Twitter
flip flop for me I want to see how this
guy's handling this issue and what he
says I just want to get your reaction
Jed you and Vinnie specifically what
reaction I want to go okay go to my
Twitter go to uh uh just go to my
account Rob just go to my profile the
Untouchable he's the untouched and if
you go down on videos go a little bit
lower go go it should be like the fourth
one keep going keep there it is right
there make that bigger and I want you to
see we have to get away from this Blame
Game Folk there's too much blaming going
on go ahead and play this clip for us
but I want to know what you think
you and the community got wrong was the
closing of the schools to draculous you
take responsibility how much of a delay
did the fact that nobody fully
understood the asymptomatic spread of
this nobody figured out that it could
actually bust through certain vaccine
levels as well what other
takeaways the real lessons I think we
have to get away from the blame game
because so many of the things that you
have mentioned were unknowns at the time
it's so easy and I made that comment uh
in my response to one of the questions
that Davis Wallace weld asked me in this
is in the New York Times profile in the
New York Times profile and I didn't mean
it as an affront to him but I said you
know this is really big time Monday
morning quarterbacking here
is it listen to me and I know I know the
viewer the real viewers that get what
I'm saying this is the most protected
bureaucrat rat they brought them out he
did exactly what he did he's been I have
videos on my phone of him flip
flip-flopping about the mask and this is
what pisses me off Judd zero
accountability how many Congressional
hearings Judiciary hearings where Rand
Paul is screaming at him and they're in
your face evidence you funded this you
did all this nothing will happen to him
zero Pat was talking about investigation
here and while this all that stuff no I
get that you will never see this guy for
all the people that died for all the
that he funded he'll never see a
prison none of them do and it frustrates
somebody like me because I'm sitting
there and I'm saying okay the left is
the left is the right just there to bark
and bark just to show us oh look there's
two sides and I don't think there is any
side yet they don't give a and they
just have us they have us by the well it
depends what part of the right you're
talking about if you're talking about
controlled opposition which absolutely
exists they're just you know they do
this they give you the illusion of
actually fighting guys like this guy's a
loathsome right he is a loathsome
creature he makes villains you know when
you turn on a superhero movie and you
see a villain this guy makes them 100 he
is that guy and the only person that
really Rivals him in turn in terms of
villainous energy is like Cloud Schwab I
also can turn that guy on and there's a
darkness that emanates from them
juxtapose him by the way with like a
Tucker Carlson who we talked about the
strength of Tucker Carlson as being able
to say I got it wrong I did something
wrong you know I I I would do it
differently now even when he was talking
about when Tucker there was a video um
he was on a podcast I think it was full
sound podcast I'm not sure and he was
talking about corporate media and he was
saying I've been on those panels I've
done that myself and it's it's loathsome
the ability to do that all fauci has to
come out and say is you know what we got
it wrong if we had to do it again we'd
do things differently but he can't so
committed to the talking point and he
also knows there's going to be no
consequence for the lies and the deceit
he is a loathsome creature my skin
crawls when he speaks
same as me and you're right then Jay
going off your thing about Tucker Tucker
literally in this interview he said you
know what he said he goes like he goes I
was pro-iraq war he goes I up he
goes I I'm telling you guys I messed up
and that to me grounds you as a person
and makes me go because you're
trustworthy I trust you because you
messed up and admitted how can you trust
a guy who when all the data emerges that
he was wrong still can't take
responsibility fauci was responsible for
giving directives about the lockdowns
for giving directives that led local and
state leadership to enforce mandates to
enforce all of this stuff he was at the
top of the chain he's the reason that
people lost their businesses he's the
reason that little kids were going to
school with masks on he is the reason
the data does not support those
decisions so what kind of human could
you ever trust again if they can't own
up he's disgusting I love that you hate
him just as much as I do he's loathsome
he is the system yep no it's it's worse
than that I think it's I think it's even
worse than that I think that it's not
just fouchy it's everything that
protects and abettes about you right now
that is the soulless leadership of of
the country and we need much different
leaders to emerge this is this is really
Stark you mean you do have people like
Rand Paul but Rand Paul gets portrayed
at least a far right-wing guy he's uh
he's he's medically trained and
everything and he's going to scream a
lot let's just get through this whenever
he's in a hearing you know you get that
that that's how they that's how media
puts Rand Paul in a box okay here goes
around Paul get ready this is what
you're going to see but really what you
have is a soulless government that is um
aiding and abetting everything that
happened here and it's um it's
disgusting it's not just here too just
as a note got used to eating and betting
your soulless government it's remember
this is bigger than the United States
fauci is not only supported by soulless
horrific leadership in this country but
you got to bring in your three-letter
organizations you've got to be really in
who the w e f this guy is supported by
heavy big Pharma institutions is a deep
deep dark because I thought when you
said it's not just that I thought we
were getting into Satan Khan frankly
because there's a difference no joke
there is a deep Darkness going on here
and people don't want to I know even
chucker invoked the supernatural the
other day something ugly is happening
here when it comes to the evilness of
these policies there's something really
dark happening there's a battle of good
versus
there has to be accountability so by the
way whoever runs next if there's no
accountability people lose trust in the
system there has to be accountability
for what he's doing uh what what is
always great what what is always great
is the following here's what's always
great it's for somebody to invest money
into doing a real documentary on him who
is willing to go do the interviews and
the legwork it may take a million it may
take three million it may take five
million and Netflix and Hulu and some of
these guys may not even take that
documentary may need to go to a
independent Ott to put it out there for
people to see there's a lot of different
ways to do it but somebody needs to make
the right investment maybe even get
involved with an RFK from the research
standpoint go interview some of the
older people that used to work at the
places and put that documentary up I'm
not talking about like
vaxxed or any of that give both sides
give stuff that he's done right give
stuff that he's won as well and then
give the other side of the argument and
then put that documentary out there
because somebody like this if there is
anything there he says we can't talk
about blame you know we have to blame
where the origin came out if you blamed
uh Trump you blamed a lot of average
people that are sitting there saying
dude I don't irresponsible Governors
irresponsible this no there needs to be
the blame and and you being held
accountable for it so this goes to two
last stories I got here I want to wrap
up with one from transgendered to trans
abled guys this is a real story now
people are choosing to identify as
handicapped this is not a joke onion
story this is not an onion story this is
not a Babylon B story this is a Fox news
story transablism or body Integrity
identity disorder can you actually
Google this to see if this is a real
thing I did
B I actually go copy paste and see if
something will come up biid okay it is a
societal issue in this is not a this is
Nia this is real this is not a joke and
it is a societal issue in which
individuals identify as handicapped and
may even ask doctors to amputate healthy
limbs snip sniper cords
spinal cords or destroy eyesight this
term has been relabeled to align with
the Trans Community with some Advocates
harnessing the cultural power of gender
ideology to cause of allowing doctors to
treat
biid patients
some people with biid mutilate
themselves which is why culturally trans
ableism is being called the next Abyss
the National Institute of Health notes
that those with biid desire
for a desire amputations or paralysis
one North Carolina college student has
called transablism a cry for attention
and Arizona internist has labeled a
delusional disorder while some doctors
may be willing to perform procedures
these doctors have issues for
transablism most will only perform those
they feel are medically indicated
I don't think I've ever used that word
but when are we as a society gonna stop
pretending okay this isn't trans oh
ableism it's called it for what it is
it's trans stupidityism okay but these
people have mental disorders okay
they're dying for attention and instead
of going out right there go be an actor
go do something you're gonna cut your
lit like one lady she was on that Dr
Phil jet she poured acid in her eyes
she's sitting there looking that she'd
even know where the hell to look you how
do you think these people that are
actually handy what do you mean Port
acid on the right this lady Pat she want
she goes I was born and I identif I
wanted to be handicapped so she poured
acid in her eyes man she went that lady
this lady that lady right there look at
her and then you play this just play for
a second to see how she sounds
regrets about taking your own Vision or
the process with which you you did take
care of it look I don't have any regrets
taking my vision thank you
I believe I should have been born blind
this is not a spoof
um
in the end I'm happy
this is unbelievable
it's a really hard time sitting next to
this really hard time
sitting so close to someone who
traumatized herself who damaged herself
we took an oath in medicine to help
people we see horrible tragedies every
single day as doctors and people who
would give anything to go back and
restore their Vision their health Jesus
my heart is beating out of my chest I
can't even make sense of the emotions
I'm feeling because to hear someone say
I've I've always felt I should be blind
well I've always felt I should be the
queen of England but I'm not going out
to become the being of English
[Music]
and listen I understand like listen
everybody here wants to park in the
handicap spot but chopping off your leg
or doing this type of stuff to park
close to a building is absurd and Jed I
I said like a lot of this stems from
this whole movement the whole trans all
of it I think it started when
disciplining your children became taboo
because think about it if Pat be honest
if one day you're like you know what Dad
I'm I'm not I'm Patricia now what would
your father have done to you Pat be
honest with me what would Gabriel have
done and I'm being genuine if you can
came home to your dad was probably
watching and he said Papa you know what
I have Patrick this Patrick schmetric I
want to be Patricia what is your father
and you're dead serious what did your
father do to you I couldn't even tell
you because that thought is confusing
for for me to even think about you know
I mean I played a lot of great pranks on
the guy that you fell for what but that
this this is above that though this is
like to to allow people to get to this
point the okay so we're having this
conversation with my sister at the house
yeah okay we went out this weekend we're
watching Blue Angels we had a great time
it was sick right but we're having this
conversation my sister
about uh uh lgbtq and the direction is
gone and transgender and all this other
stuff I think
you you parents are playing a very
slippery slope where they're kind of
like no it's okay you know do whatever
you want to do no no it's okay you know
to each his own no it's okay it's not to
each his own this person got three and a
half million views okay how many other
women see this kids and they're gonna be
like well I relate to this if I'm gonna
get this much eyeballs and I'm finally
gonna get some attention I'll do
something like this of course I'm
willing to do this to my body and if
they don't have love in their household
they don't have any encouragement in
their household nothing like that's
going to be happening kids are going to
make some stupid decisions with their
lives because of this people can't sit
on the sidelines and say the argument of
it's our choice let her do whatever she
wants to do with her body no you have to
have mental issues to be willing to do
something like this to yourself that has
to be clear and it can't be like sitting
aside and saying I'm good with my life I
think I think the the lack of calling
out and calling out you know uh
uh insanity is causing a lot of people
to think this is the norm Dwayne Wade
the other day said I have to leave the
state of Florida because it just didn't
match my values and principles bye and
we decided to go to a different place
where our you know son daughter is it a
son or daughter now what is it now it's
a guy that wants to be a guy I'm
confused I don't know so but the point
is we had to leave the state of Florida
okay well good for you bro
congratulations to wherever else you
moved to because you are trying to
protect your you know transgender child
now what are you going to say if this 26
year old kid one day this kid of yours
one day is 26 and says Dad why did you
let me do that at 13 years old well what
are you gonna do well I don't know how
old a kid is by the way what are you
gonna do when one day your kid says that
why did you let me go through that
process I was delusional at that time
then what's your argument going to be
dad what are you going to say then
there's a lot of stuff that kids will
say to their parents and 15 year old now
it's a 15 year old kid just a lot of
things that kids will say to their
parents we have to straight up start
calling out weird strange crazy the
ideas like this that we're even doing an
episode today about trans ableism what
are your thoughts on this jet well I
mean what's interesting is you see the
audience reaction and we can all be like
look at the audience look at the people
on the channel they're all horrified and
my response is give it 10 years give it
10 years because you know what 20 years
ago if you had brought somebody in that
was a child that was on you know all
these hormone pills and whatnot if you
looked at mutilation that people are
doing in their own bodies
you know to I'm a girl I want to be a
boy this that people would have
commented on that in the same way would
have said well wait a minute this is
very concerning but now these same
people if you brought out what I just
said if you brought out people in the
trans community and whatnot these very
same people on the panel will be very
hesitant to say anything bad about that
so you have this like we're adjusting to
a new normal all the time and what you
have is a lot of people I mean this is
mental illness right 100 I mean 100 100
wrong either it's mental illness or it's
social contagion or it's a desire for
popularity and there's been a lot of
allegations against Mulvaney by the way
Dylan Mulvaney that people say who knew
him said oh this is all to get
popularity look at all the money that
Dill mulvania is making now there are
people that are willing to do anything
for money so I think there's a lot of
undiagnosed mental illness there's a lot
of normalization of mental illness
there's a lot of social Contagion on
social media where people who are lost
and struggling and maybe going through
some mental stuff on their own think
this is their way to find new oh this is
where I'm really gonna find my space
where I'm gonna be happy you see kids
being manipulated heavily in those
spaces did you see Duke Health my sister
just sent me this took medicine opened
its gender clinic in 2015 okay
and they offer a wide variety of
Services Under One Roof if you can find
this okay put Duke Medicine gender
Clinic Duke Medicine gender Clinic
uh right there so they offer a variety
of Services Under One Roof the clinic
treats children as young as two for
gender dysphoria yeah this is sickness
now I mean I have a three-year-old right
we saw him Duke University that's right
and that and that's the other thing that
people people don't take it that extra
step because again
these are the the American you know all
of these traditional medicine facilities
again I always bring in Pharma there's a
lot of cash cow here there's a lot of
money to be made off of lifelong
commitment to once you have a surgery
you have to take these hormones there's
so much formal money to be made here
that you're gonna have media endorsement
of strange things you're going to have
you know medical institutions that you
once deemed respectable and you were
like well this was a respectable
institution first of all was it and
secondly who do they report to what is
their end game there's a lot of money to
be made in this very very disturbing
stuff and who suffers people mostly
young young kids that are now being
roped into this I think there's a lot of
money under it when we look back at this
in five ten years you're going to see
the money lines be so clear I mean this
is Duke Duke used to be known as
slightly more conservative University of
North Carolina Chapel Hill was slightly
more liberal and but they weren't
enemies but they were kind of on a
spectrum like that that was the
difference and at um I think it's
Flagler which was the MBA school at
Chapel Hill and then you had Fuqua Fuqua
which was the MBA school at Duke and it
was a little bit more conservative
actually a lot more conservative and now
you look and you see the med school
that's at Duke and it's really Stark
it's really those of us that know people
that 15 years ago 20 years ago graduated
either school I am shocked to see this
but I think there is I think there's a
money path here that's even bigger and I
agree with what has already been said
this is all about attention everybody
wants a box to check to get their
attention and to get their their Vibe
and you've got people that are doing
this for sport I think when it's I'd
love to see where villamovania is in 10
years five years and find out and find
out if he's back on the other side and
kind of jokes about the fact that he
cashed the check
okay this is crazy to me folks if you're
listening to this it's absolute Insanity
that this is taking place by the way if
you enjoyed today's podcast uh I believe
Mario and Kai just send me a message
saying we were the number one Live on
YouTube in America on the home page of
YouTube showed us today as a live we
have 10 000 plus people live the
internet let's go because phenomenal job
people love Jed do people love Vinnie
they love Tom this was a great show here
today but we got also a message here uh
uh an announcement to make I want to
show you guys a box I just got I'm going
to show you in a box I got a box I want
to show you guys it's a crazy box let's
say it's a crazy box if you can bring
the box here for us to show to everybody
oh wow there's a surprise in this box
you have a box now there is a small
little pet that we have fine if what if
the boss can bring it in can you open
the door to see if they're outside or no
yeah
so here's what the box is the box is
today today and yesterday were Vincent
oshana and Mario Aguilar's birthday so
come on in we gotta sing happy birthday
you got
come around on three we'll sing along if
you guys know Mario VT with me what it
is without Mario and Vinny's birthday
today as well on three we gotta sing for
you guys on three one two three happy
birthday to you
happy birthday to you
happy
birthday to you
[Applause]
thank you guys we're both 25 years old
look how good we look I love it sexy as
hell so tell us go ahead shout out to
the entire audience because without you
guys watching we wouldn't have a value
team of brand shout out to pbd I've
never met somebody who can Outlast this
long I've been working with you for 18
years and uh if it wasn't for Patrick
sticking it out we wouldn't be here
shout out to our team who makes every
day possible and to our talent who has
makes the future look bright thank you
everybody Mario and shout out to your
future son let's go baby
let's go
yeah a
yes happy birthday to you guys Jen you
have a show today or your show's uh
Wednesday Monday Wednesday Friday
Wednesday Friday 1 p.m Eastern Time be
there 1pm Eastern Time Conway Monday
show it's a comedy uh variety show it's
on Wednesdays at 4 P.M eastern time
we've got the links to everybody under
description so they know to go find them
Monday 11 30 a.m Eastern we will do this
again do we have podcasts on Thursday or
no we do it'll be at 12 o'clock on
Thursday uh with Peter Navarro Peter
Navarro yes okay sounds good so
Wednesday no Thursday 12 o'clock Peter
Navarre take care everybody bye-bye
bye-bye
I